the International Monetary Fund says the
corona virus pandemic will cost the
world's economies 9 trillion dollars
over the next two years the warning
comes as countries around the world face
prolonged lock downs as they try to
contain the outbreak the IMF chief
economist says it is the worst economic
shock since the Great Depression of the
1930s flattening the spread of Ko in
nineteen using lock downs allows health
systems to cope with this crises which
then permits a resumption of economic
activity in the sense there is no
trade-off between saving lives and
saving livelihoods countries should
continue to continue to generously
support their health systems perform
widespread testing and refrain from
trade restrictions on medical supplies a
global effort must ensure that when
therapies and vaccines are developed
both rich and poor nations alike have
immediate access our correspondent Alan
Fisher tracking this story for us this
hour on the NewsHour so Alan this will
be focusing minds when it comes to
finance ministers around the world it is
a pretty stark assessment from the
International Monetary Fund that the
global economy will essentially contract
by three percent in the first quarter
and they're hoping that in the second
half of the year things will improve but
they admit that that might not be the
case if the situation gets worse if the
lockdowns continue then this just might
be the brighter sight of the economic
forecast of course there is always the
opportunity that things could actually
get better and certainly we believe that
may well happen if there is to be a
recovery in 2021 seeing that in that
time we could see the gut the whole
global economy rebounding by about five
point eight percent but it will be slow
and it will be patchy because different
countries will come out of this at
different points talking about how it
impacts the various parts of the world
in the United States you're talking
about a loss of five point nine percent
in the economy in Europe where they use
the euro so excluding the UK five point
seven percent in Japan don't buy five
2% and China growth of just 1% now it
looks as if China is getting out of this
quite well but when you consider that
last year they reported growth of 6% you
can see just how severely that has hit
their economy what the IMF says is that
when all this is done you have to get
away from the idea of D globalization
because that wouldn't help the global
economy and also there has to be fiscal
stimulus across several countries it has
to be coordinated it can't just be
piecemeal and they say in that way that
could rebuild the global economy by 2021
but as I say a stark assessment from the
International Monetary Fund and as far
as the US economy is concerned
specifically Alan where you are Donald
Trump is saying look I am the guy who
can or will choose not to restart the
economy when the time is right other
people saying no it has to happen in
stages and on top of that what you had
what claims for 16 17 million people
putting in claims for Social Security in
the states in the space of 3 weeks and
that's never happened before
ever in the US no Donald Trump to be
clear Donald Trump doesn't have the
power to order States to reopen what he
can do is put a great deal of pressure
on a number of states a number of
Governors and say look you have to do
this but he doesn't have the power to
reopen the economy and many states are
very much in line with public thinking
in this which is we will reopen when the
scientists see it see though there are a
number of organizations who are tied to
donald trump's reelection effort who
would be regarded in this country it's
right-wing who are saying that they are
going to start organizing protests
demanding that the economy be reopened
and it may well be there is a gradual
reopening but you remember that donald
trump was talking about having the
economy up and running again by Easter
well that was last Sunday he's no
talking about me the first that seems
unlikely when a number of states are
saying that their peak is still two
weeks away so that would take us towards
that date this is going to be a long
slow process and you have to see it
through Donald Trump's eyes he sees it
through the prism of
if there is a strong economy then he
will be real
that's what he believes that is what his
campaign has been building on and that
is what been building up to the point
when the virus hit and he thinks if this
continues then the economy will be
wrecked he will get the blame and
therefore he won't be reelected that is
why he is very keen to reopen the
economy as soon as possible
but looking at the figures from the IMF
and what Donald Trump is saying it seems
unlikely that in the second quarter
which would take us through to June for
those who don't speak financial talk
which would take us to the end of June
they are saying that this is going to
impact the global economy and it's going
to impact the United States and it could
well go on for a period after that as
well Ellen thanks very much let's bring
in Gareth lever he's a senior economist
at Capital Economics a consultancy in
London Gareth welcome back to al-jazeera
these numbers are staggering what do
they mean and they are and I think that
is because the economic shock that we're
facing now is unprecedented the large
parts of the global economy are
effectively shut down to contain the
spread of the coronavirus and until
health officials and governments are
confident that the virus has been
contained these measures will remain in
place and the economic shock will
continue we're seeing some economies
begin just to loosen the strictures
inside which they've been operating lock
downs or partial lock downs or near lock
downs will the easing of those economic
stays if you will go any way to mitigate
the staggering figures that we're
discussing from the IMF I think they
will this what you probably see is that
the global economy probably shouldn't
maybe 10% this quarter but as the shut
downs are unlocked you will initially at
least get a very strong rebound as shops
and factories are reopened but I think
then the global economy will start to
face a number of headwinds in the form
of very weak demand that lots of
companies have gone bust through this
unemployment is a lot higher and all of
that will drag on global growth as well
some sectors for example most notably
tourism are going to take a very long
time indeed to recover and when you talk
about that kind of knock-on effect a
domino effect almost
six or twelve months down the line you
know we've seen say in the past 24 hours
people returning to industries like the
building trade that's good they're
making money again people are building
houses but no one's gonna build the her
negatives are buy the houses rather
because they can't get a mortgage
because they've lost their jobs no
exactly so you will get this initial
bounce back and economic activity as
shocks and so on it opened up but
straight after that I think he'd gone
into running through a lot of headwinds
in terms of the kind of the drag that's
gonna come from all of the the big shock
that's happened over the past quarter in
terms of bankruptcies in terms of lost
jobs and that is gonna weigh quite
heavily on demand and that is why
governments and central banks have been
stepping up stimulus to try and give the
economy this extra boost when it comes
out of this shock that's been induced by
these shutdowns what form all that
stimulus take Bali is its multiform so
central banks have cut interest rates
and in places where interest rates in
are zero they've introduced quantitative
easing
governments have also been loosening
fiscal policies so in some countries
it's in the form of cash giveaways to
people it's in the form of very cheap
loans to companies to make sure that
they can they can get through the crisis
but all this is really kind of disaster
relief at the moment is to make sure
that these companies can get through the
crisis I think in the third quarter
you'll need another boost from
governments as well to provide the extra
support to demand that's going to be
lacking from the private sector because
of unemployment and higher debt levels
and so on careth leather thank you very
much
thank you well as if that economic news
wasn't bad enough the world's airlines
now stand to lose more than three
hundred billion dollars in revenue this
year that's the latest forecast from
IATA that's the overall industry's
representative body carriers have
grounded aircraft and crew of course
amid a growing number of travel
restrictions and border closures let's
go straight to our economics editor a
Batali who joins us on skype from London
Abbott great to be here on the NewsHour
this is kind of the blow that the
airline industry was waiting on landing
on top of it wasn't it Peter you're
absolutely right you know the industry
employs
some in the region are 65 million people
directly and indirectly and so you know
they're expecting 25 million jobs could
be lost over the next three months
unless governments step in with health
now we had in the United States that the
Trump administration that has said
they'll give sixty billion dollars to
the airline industry but the airline
industry has been reluctant to take
those on because part of that money
comes in the form of loans and quite
rightly so many people would think and
some of the money cannot be used to buy
back shares or dividends or any or pay
executives huge bonuses as has been the
case in the previous previous financial
crisis in 2008 so they're reluctant to
take the money and when you look at the
for instance in the UK the British
government has said listen you know
we're not going to hand out huge
bailouts to help put the airlines and
when we'll take each airline case by
case and see see what support we can
offer but the first port of call you
need to go to your shareholders to get
your money and you got really share
waste now then in the process of for
loaning 30,000 employees so this is very
real economy kind of stuff this is
people's lives being affected and they
put this into the wider context because
the global tourism industry is such a
huge industry it's about almost nine
trillion dollars is the actual value of
it and it employs more than 300 people
around the world and it's not just
Airlines it's hotels it's cruise ships
and it's it's your air B & Bs you know
little the little guys are suffering as
much as the big guys okay when we talk
about the little guys and the big big
guys in the context of the airline
industry I noticed on Twitter British
Airways is scrapping one 747 per day
every day this week
so my question is this will this
directly impact the low-cost carriers
for whom the profit margins are very
small or the big legacy carriers the
share ways the American Airlines the the
Qantas type airline set up you know
those big legacy carriers who've been
around for 50 60 70 years so very
interesting question now here's the
thing British Airways has taken and
pontius they've taken lessons from the
low-cost airlines and so they've been
reducing their costs you know when you
go internet onto an aeroplane you know
they'll be giving you a sandwich rather
than a full meal and they'll be reducing
other other costs as well along the way
so you know you're paying for your
baggage just like you do for the
low-cost airlines this is gonna hit all
airlines I don't think that you know is
this this pandemic pandemic or
discriminate as to you know who gets
affected the most
so all airlines will need some kind of
funding or will need some kind of boring
to get them through this particular
process in the US for instance if if
small airlines are worrying they're
under 100 million dollars they don't
have to abide by the rules which say you
know you can't use this money for
anything anything else like dividends or
whatever this this is money for you to
keep people in jobs and so I think
you're going to see the same kind of
support around the world from from from
government to to Airlines which will be
specific to say this money that we give
you is entirely for keeping people in
work and anything else you need to go to
your shareholders to find the money
habit thanks very much